we are excited for a very special
edition of Talk of the table we are
joined by our friends Drew Barrymore
host of The Drew Barrymore Show and her
Drew's news
Ross Matthews
just instagramming about us good morning
everybody good morning so we're joining
forces as we often do to bring you some
of the stories that we're all talking
about this morning it's called talk at
the table we got a table we're talking
Drew you are in proposition Drew comes
first oh thank you Gail okay my talk of
the table is about online dating now
there are a lot of new words that
younger people people that are under 25
are using to describe their dating life
and older adults have no idea what they
mean so Tinder Australia decided to
write a dictionary to help explain what
these new words mean here are some
examples date view that term is when a
date feels more like an interview that's
good getting fish hey is when you
embellish aspects of your life on dating
apps different than catfishing when you
pretend to be someone else entirely and
now she sounds catty this one it does I
like it's called the situationship it's
the in-between period when you're more
than a fling but not quite a couple and
if you like that Gail yes situation I
know I feel like that feels more apt to
my life and cushioning is when you keep
several backup relationships going to
cushion the blow in case that makes
sense to me does it work the sitting in
my day meant something different
conversations a little more Universal so
that everyone can share in what Vlad is
saying
we don't judge I'm scared to find out
what that means
back to my diary from the 90s again
notice I'm not asking any follow-up
questions
all right well you know air travel has
gotten a lot of flack lately right well
my talk at the table is about plane
safety demonstrations and it's a fun
story because we always used to have to
we sit through those demonstrations when
you when you fly the flight attendants
do it but a Southwest flight attendant
recently decided to give passengers sort
of a unique show that was a lot of fun
take a look oh there are six Emergency
Services
[Music]
[Laughter]
on Twitter went viral and the headline
was the best Southwest flight attendant
ever hashtag give him a raise I know I
wish we knew his name because now if
people have gotten so used to it they
don't pay a 10 engine but you should
always pay attention to the safety thing
I like when he popped the collar and he
got the attention
man is Saving Lives yeah he is Gail
you're next my talk at the table is more
of our interview before you guys came we
had a interview with Daniel Eck the head
guy on Spotify you were watching I was
wrong because they've changed their
their page so we talked about AI also
known as artificial intelligence it's
quite a bit at this table we're talking
about that too it's become such a huge
part of the future of technology so we
wanted to hear what he thinks about that
the AI technology does it scare you any
in any way it doesn't it doesn't I think
on a broader scale uh it is it is kind
of crazy to imagine what the world may
look like in five or ten years if we go
to what people call AGI artificial
general intelligence which basically
means that you have an AI that might be
smarter than any human alive right so
that's kind of daunting to think about
what the consequences might be for
Humanity
us were there and I think we have to be
very careful about it but at the same
time on the other side it's also so
obvious that AI can help so much by
making you know both experiences better
and easier for all of us to deal with
and that's pretty much in every single
field
it reminds me of the conversation you
had with the head of guide at Microsoft
yeah it's under everybody's looking at
AI yep is it frightening you guys
well it was interesting like there's uh
we did a story on how college students
can now access a program where they just
say what the subject is and it's right
the paper for you and then I said okay
let me do one next to you typing in
something slightly different and it gave
me a completely different report it
doesn't repeat itself like it's that
smart right it's also that dumb right if
you ask you questions like what's
heavier a pound of feathers or a pound
of rocks it'll say the Rocks is you know
when they're both interesting and it
also will get facts wrong sometimes and
make stuff up so you know if you're a
college kid using it you're not going to
be an a student you might be having a
good time student but you'll be an AI
students
[Applause]
my talk on the table is something we all
have a vested interest in and it's what
people wear at the beach or the pool or
the lake as the weather warms and in
particular Speedo so there's a deal
oh the Dear Prudence question here from
a 46 year old happily married
heterosexual male who says I don't like
the baggy shorts that they make us wear
they being the culture at large I want
to wear a Speedo his concern is I swim
at the lake in my town uh and and there
are children there and families and I
don't want to make a giant scene or ruin
the place for others so the question is
will Waring a tight-fitting suit for
this individual be seen as creepy or
sexual what does he look like oh that's
that's not clear
I'll tell you what Dear Prudence had to
say if anyone else wants to wait yeah I
don't like Speedo she said go for it go
for it uh ubu uh just you know lean into
your self-consciousness uh when it comes
to walking around don't just kind of
make you know linger
don't be creeping then people might get
the wrong idea Tony would you wear a
Speedo quick around the table it would
involve too much shaving for me oh my
gosh well I'll tell you I'm actually
wearing one right now
my talk on the table is a new meaning of
cushioning there Gail uh my turn on the
table is a new Beauty filter that's
getting a lot of attention on Tick Tock
some good some bad it's called bold
glamor it all the girls faces in real
time it creates an enhanced version or
Avatar of the user and some say unlike
the other filters out there this one
does not stop working even with sudden
movement so that makes it hard for
people to realize it's even being used
so we decided of course to give the
filter a try watch this
in the makeup chair getting that TV face
clearly no filter let's see what they do
and this is me with the filter
I'm thinking I still need radon thank
you Glam filter thank you but no all
right this is me with no filter but a
face full of TV makeup and this is me
with a face full of TV makeup and an AI
filter this is me without the filter
this is me with the filter
this is me without the filter
okay here's me before I know gorgeous
and he hears me after okay oh I am a
real housewife hello
what do you guys think
did you blow a kiss at the camera I did
you got to give the people what they
want give us one more black one more
give the people what they want but there
are some really Drew shots don't
encourage that
I don't I have to say that I was happy
that I didn't dislike the before for
myself and my only fear is that people
with when they see the filter they'll
like themselves better that's right and
I did not like the filter version of
myself and you don't want for the other
one or too many healthy it is out there
and issues around Beauty and what is
beauty for especially young women
totally that a nap a nap like this could
be detriment doesn't look really pretty
I have to say I'm with you I kind of
like how I look really pretty I can't
wait to get all that work done for real
fine
thank you love yourself
we're going to leave you with that
it was pretty you're not wrong thank you
guys thank you thank you very much
Drew Barrymore show weekdays on stations
around the country as they say check
your local listing